Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
The faithful simulation of human skin is incredibly
important both in computer games, the movie
industry, and also in medical sciences.
The appearance of our face is strongly determined
by the underlying structure of our skin. Human
skin changes significantly with age. It becomes
thinner and more dry, while the concentration
of chromophores, the main skin pigments diminishes
and becomes more irregular. Those pigment
concentrations are determined by our age,
gender, skin type and even external factors
like, for example exposition to UV radiation
or our smoking habits. As we age, the outermost
layer of our skin, the epidermis thins, the
melanine, haemoglobin and water concentration
levels drop over time.
As you could image having a plausible
simulation considering all the involved actors
is fraught with difficulties.
Scientists at the University of Zaragoza came
up with a really cool, fully-fledged biophysically-based
model that opens up the possibility of simply
specifying intuitive parameters like age,
gender, skin type, and get, after some processing,
a much lighter skin representation ready to
generate photorealistic rendered results in
real time.
Luckily, one can record diffusion profiles,
also called scattering profiles that tell
us the color of light that is reflected by
our skin. In this image, above, you can see
a rendered image and the diffusion profiles
of a 30 and an 80 year old person. The idea
is the following: you specify intuitive inputs
like age and skin type, then run a detailed
simulation once, that creates these diffusion
profiles that you can use forever in your
rendering program. And all this is done in
a way that is biophysically impeccable.
I was sure that there was some potential in
this topic, but when I first saw these results,
they completely crushed my expectations. Excellent piece of work!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!